[Music]
indeed good afternoon so today the eu
has reached a crucial milestone with 70
of the adult population now fully
vaccinated
in total some 256 million adults in the
eu have now received a full vaccine
course
this follows the commission's delivery
target being met last month ahead of
time to provide member states by the end
of july with enough vaccine doses to
fully vaccinate 70 percent of the adult
eu population
however the pandemic is of course not
over a safe and effective vaccine is our
best chance to beat
the coronavirus and return to our normal
lives
everyone who can should get vaccinated
europe will also continue to support its
partners in this effort in particular
low and middle-income countries
thank you very much
for continuing
good afternoon
everybody tomorrow on wednesday the 1st
of september a new version of the eu
energy label for light bulbs and
lighting products will become applicable
in shops and online retail
outlets
the eu energy label is a widely
recognized feature on household products
93 of consumers recognize the labels and
for 79 of them it has influenced their
purchasing decisions
light bulbs and lighting products have
become much more energy efficient in
recent years many of them have achieved
a plus or a plus plus ratings on the
current scale
this is why we now need to rescale the
labels and leave space for further
improvements in the future without
confusing consumers
as of tomorrow we will return to a
simpler a to g scale the most energy
efficient lighting products which are
currently on the market will now
typically be labeled as c or d
a number of new elements will also be
featured on the labels including a qr
code which links to an eui database
where consumers can find more details
about the product
more information about the new labels
which you can also see
behind us here on the screen are
available in the press release which
we've just published
thank you
thank you
thank you very much tim
um
[Music]
treasure
[Music]
we
it's marie absarav for
rick tv today it's the
cypriot public television
so my question will be cyprus related do
you have any update on the
oil spill that is spreading from syria
to cyprus
is there any reaction to this and how
can the commission help the situation
thank you
thank you very much
good afternoon i would believe that you
were referring to an accident that
happened over the weekend uh of uh
of the coasts of uh of greece
we were and we have been in touch with
the greek authorities uh uh in this
context
um at the moment i'm not aware of any uh
concrete requests from from their site
uh but
we continue to be um in touch with them
by our emergency crisis uh center so
should i should i have any updates on
this i will i will come back to in the
afternoon
thank you very much are there other
questions for balash on this issue
that is not the case thank you balash
and i therefore go to francesco who has
a question on another issue
yeah uh good morning my question is on
your target that 70 percent
uh target that has been achieved today
uh
do you consider do you you 50 the target
you can say that the target has been
reached
given that uh many countries in the east
uh are still uh
far below the target i mean the target
was
interpreted as being
my country not uh
as a
cumulative figure for the youth so given
that there are still many
countries in the east that are far below
70 percent can they use a
that has reached the 70 percent target
and then secondly
on boosters uh
there were some comments made today both
by
in your press release
by
commissioner kiryat
do you have any advice uh
for member states that are planning or
have already started them
uh their policy to to to use boosters to
offer the
dose or second in the case of johnson
johnson even if there is no uh
no
data yet that
prove that boosters are needed or that
boosters are not
are safe actually
with the wto saying that
this can also be negative in the fight
against the variants given that
variants spread mostly among the people
that are not vaccinated
and giving boosters to
people that already vaccinated in a
moment in which there aren't enough
vaccines for the entire world means that
more people
could be exposed to uh to the virus and
then to new variants thanks
thank you very much francesco uh you
have two questions um on the first let
me very very clear um we are not
speaking of a target here let me remind
you that the target was
for the you to deliver
vaccines in sufficient quantities in
order to be in a position to vaccinate
70 percent of adults across the european
union and this target has been reached
already quite some time ago
here
we are only referring to the fact that
a threshold has been reached across the
european uh union albeit obviously you
are right to point out with
significant differences
across certain uh member states
and the threshold is 70 of adults fully
vaccinated but the objective which the
commission had set for its own actions
when it comes
to the management of the pandemic was
the delivery of um of enough doses
because a responsibility for vaccination
remains with member states and that
being said
as you will have seen from
the announcement that balesh has made
and also from the messages that our
accounts have been publishing today
we definitely consider that the effort
must continue that we need
member states need to continue their
efforts in order to ensure that more and
more people
are
are vaccinated
on your second question
concerning booster shots now as you know
it is not for the commission
to give
such
such recommendations for that we have
the ecdc and the european medicines
agency
they are looking into this issue and
will come forward certainly with their
recommendation on this in due time
are there other questions for us on the
health issue today
that is not the case so let's move to
another issue yes
go ahead please take the microphone
this is khalid amit faruqi from jio
television news pakistan and young group
of newspapers
i would like to ask
that pakistan have been
cordially supporting
the evacuation of
european citizen and european
commission staff and imf from
afghanistan
will there be some sort of cordial
reciprocity
which pakistan expect from eu
on direct issues like fatf and
pakistan international airlines banned
to fly in
europe and also the threat removal of
threat of
gsp plus
trade concession scheme
which is
now with the commission for suspension
on the behalf of european parliament
these three issues pakistan people of
pakistan expect some sort of leniency on
these issues and european union must
look at it thank you
thank you i believe the last part was a
statement rather the question but on the
question of our relations with pakistan
overall i will give the floor
to peter
thank you and i'll try to be very brief
because all the issues you mentioned are
very particular issues where uh the
talks and discussions and engagement uh
might be ongoing already so without
preempting anything i can only restate
that the eu is committed to work with
partners on all the issues based on the
policy of mutual benefit that means if
there is mutual benefit possible for
both sides we are proceeding if it's in
line with our policies in line with our
interests and of course we always take
the needs of the partners into account
right now what is most important from
the european point of view is our
engagement with pakistan when it comes
to afghanistan because this is the most
pressing need right now the crisis and
the development in afghanistan have many
many implications on the neighboring
countries such as pakistan but also on
europe that's why our focus right now is
really to engage with pakistan to focus
on how to prevent the negative spillover
of events from pakistan of in in
afghanistan on pakistan other
neighboring countries on the region and
on the eu but of course within this
dialogue we have ongoing dialogue on all
the issues you mentioned
thank you very much other other
questions on foreign relations for peter
today
that is not the case so i go to matu who
had a question on another issue
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
we
a bit too quick
do you hear me yes no
natalia from the catalan news agency i
wanted to ask a question on transport
today is the last day of
tolls in the main
high roads in catalonia and as there is
no any
new system in place i wanted to know
um
when there should be a new system
according to the new
eu rules and especially i wanted to know
which
model the european commission recommends
in order to apply the
the polluter
base principle
thank you very much to natalia
very good questions but i think we'll
have to come back to you on a bilateral
basis uh on this as i
as i often say if you have such
technical issues on which you would like
to have answers from us it's good if we
if we can get the uh the uh the
questions in advance also uh
in advance i send the question in
advance but i guess that um ok
balash
who is
replacing stefan
must have seen it sufficiently early in
order to be able to answer so we will
come back to you on a bilateral basis
okay
sorry for that
thank you very much are there other
questions for us
that is not the case yes
and i do have my glasses on so
i should be able to see you yeah if i
could ask you to see
to sit on seats which have not a sign on
them allow you not to sit but never okay
it's been a while it's been a while
for mcmahon your news thank you for the
floor could you just give us an update
on how the meeting went yesterday
between very eurova and mattoche
marieski please
uh christian what can we say on this
so yes good afternoon
um
[Music]
i think you might have
seen that the vice president
uh
herself
tweeted about this yesterday
so i don't have a lot of much
to add to this
so
she had this meeting yesterday as i said
in the context of her of her visit
that was originally
um
or that originated
from her invitation to dansk to
participate at the commemorative events
where she just delivered
a speech um and so yesterday she had
meetings in warsaw and met with the
prime minister
and we will
continue the dialogue on rule of law and
other relevant issues
both for poland and to you as
vice president said
she called it the eu is a community of
law based mutual trust
and this is why the rulings of the
european court of justice must be fully
respected
so
that is basically what i can say i've
done it really much to add to what the
vice president set herself on this
yesterday
thank you are there other questions on
rule of law
for
christian today
no
any other issues for us
yes we're young
the afghanistan you know i
learned reports about uh
uh
can you hear me
absolutely we've already closed for the
first chapter but go ahead
i just want to see
whether the commission has any sort of
uh
uh reaction on the report that the u.s
drone strikes actually killed a family
of 10 including seven
children usually
the commission would express some
concern or condemnation i don't know is
there any
uh comment
i'm not sure if i understood
well thank you for this question you
know that in general we always regret
loss of innocent lives this is the the
bottom line of the european union and uh
uh this is very regular irregularitable
and our thoughts always go always go to
the families of uh of the victims um
when you are asking about uh specific
incident and the
u.s drone
operation or u.s military operations one
has to remember the circumstances under
which the international community the
united states are operating in
afghanistan there has been covertly
and there have been coveredly and brutal
attacks against civilians at the airport
several times since last week and this
is something we are condemning very much
we understand that a number of these
attacks have been claimed by the isis uh
the local branch in afghanistan i would
refer you to the statement issued by the
anti-daesh coalition last night it's
also on our website and it's a statement
about the situation in afghanistan in
more general from the security point of
view condemning all these attacks that
lead to loss of innocent lives
and this is all i can say at this stage
thank you very much
are there other questions for us today
yes please
in today's political newsletter there
was a piece on the rise of anti-semitism
in europe
and i was wondering what are the
concrete plans for the commission to
combat anti-semitism especially in the
wake of the corona crisis
yeah thank you thank you for the
question i mean this is indeed
a topic um on which we have been on
which we have been working
a lot uh already you know that we have a
coordinator
on combating anti-semitism that is
working
uh
with the with the jewish community
uh in europe um
and with all relevant stakeholders
um
to to to fight anti-semitism under the
leadership of
vice president marguerite schinas
and
we
are also at the moment preparing
a new strategy
on fighting anti-semitism
which is which can be expected later
later this year
so there there is a lot of work ongoing
i don't have any any particular
news to share at this point in time but
this is something that we take take very
seriously and cover from different
things
any other questions for christian on
this
any other issues
no so thank you very much and um
we will see you tomorrow
thank you